President Trump will meet with Russian
President Vladimir Putin and Chinese
President Xi Jinping at the g20 summit
in Japan next month now this meeting
comes amid an escalation of what author
Jim Sciuto calls a new type of warfare
his new book it's called the shadow war
inside Russia's and China's secret
operations to defeat America and it's on
big time it highlights tactics he says
both countries use to attack the US and
its allies but fall below the thrust the
threshold of starting a shooting war try
saying that three times
shuto is CNN's chief national security
correspondent and anchor he's also
served as chief of staff to America's
ambassador to China from 2011 to 2013
and we're delighted that you were at the
table mr. great severe thanks so much
for having me so we all have heard the
term cold war trade war but this shadow
war is a different kind of animal you
say and they use very different tactics
like it is it's a war that they are
waging Russia and China are waging on
the US and we're not fighting back and
only very recently came to terms with it
and I think Americans are aware of or
some of the fronts of this war certainly
election interference which continues
but but they're not aware of others
Russia and China have both put weapons
in space lasers kamikaze satellites
kidnapper satellites a China has
developed a satellite that could grab
other satellites out of orbit these are
satellites we depend on for the way we
live every day of our lives GPS etc but
also the military does crucially there
is a new great game under the waves
submarine warfare between the US Russia
and China submarines they're quieter
they're getting closer to us Shores
that's a way to project nuclear power
without warning right up to the US
homeland and what are they
Jim what are they trying to get and you
point out in the book that we don't seem
prepared for what is happening to us no
question they're trying China's case
they're trying outright to surpass the
US this is not a secret they say it
publicly in speeches it's in their
documents their national security
documents they they want to achieve what
they view as their rightful place on top
of the world and almost invariably
national security folks will say China
is the bigger of the two threats but but
Russia very big threat and and theirs as
more of a zero-sum game any opportunity
to stick their finger in the eye of the
United States they view as a win I spoke
with the FBI director last year and you
think about what the FBI does in turn
of countering terrorist threats he said
his top counterintelligence priority is
China
how many spies Chinese spies are in
America trying to steal and commit
economic espionage thousands here and I
spoke to the FBI's former head of
counterintelligence and tens of
thousands in China I mean he talked
about it in terms of how they have a
national service program almost for
smart young people there to hack their
way into US public and private sector
secrets and they do it with enormous
success they're stealing seed technology
agriculture technology or a fish
intelligence but also crucially national
security technology have a chapter in
the book about how over the course of
four years before they were detected a
small team of four people stole secrets
about the f-35 the c-17 and the f-22 and
today China is flying planes that look
remarkably like those planes so Jim give
us some context in terms of before 9/11
there were people who were saying
connect the darks and there were other
people who were asleep at the switch to
mix my metaphors in this case do people
know the threat is real and they're just
trying to catch up or are they still
blind to the nature of the threat it
took time it was belated but they know
today I spent time out in the field this
is the way u.s. submarine commanders
talk about the conflict today it's the
way people in the NSA operation centers
fighting cyberattacks every day it's the
way they talk about it's the way US
diplomats in Ukraine etc it is not the
way the US president talks about this
threat he will not publicly identify in
fact alarmingly he will often sound very
much like Russia on what's the practical
result of that though because what when
you as you know when you talk to
officials they'll say forget the
rhetoric we're on the case here and the
rhetoric doesn't matter well folks right
and to be clear in this book I spread
the blame around me because through
multiple administration's of Republican
and Democratic parties missed signals
over time everybody thought they could
get it right
the Bush administration thought they
could get it right Obama could get
thought he'd get it right saw the light
later Trump administration not unusual
in that respect unusual though in that
when you see the hostility the president
still won't recognize it and state it
publicly and everybody across the board
says the u.s. cannot
this war defend itself properly without
leadership from the top and they don't
have any leadership well this trade war
with China make this worse well this is
the thing and again credit where credit
is due
the president is confronting China for
instance on the theft of trade secrets
to a degree the previous administrations
would not they knew about it but but
they said listen we could get it right
bring them into the fold they were
change their behavior they have not the
president's confronting the trouble is
what the president is asking China to do
is to change its economic model at state
model this is the way it has achieved
success in its view when you battle like
that and both have advantages will China
back down I'll tell you we have internal
domestic politics so does China the last
thing a Chinese leader is gonna want to
do is be seen as backing down to the US
president help people understand why
presidential leadership is so important
without it what doesn't happen well
things like allocation of resources
making decisions to counter to counter
the threat defending US assets taking
where necessary offensive steps to
counter this threat that requires
presidential leadership it matters that
this president has only had one cabinet
level discussion of election security
that's a problem only one only one it
matters that this president you heard
this from Kirsten Nielsen as she left it
matters that this president that his
senior advisors can't even bring up the
issue of the election and Ference with
him because he won't go there yeah you
made a point of saying you're not
writing this book for politics you're
writing it you said at the end as a
concerned American I was very touched by
that and I am I spent years in Russia
and China and and seeing each front of
this war I've been on the ground in
Ukraine I've been on a u.s. under the
Arctic I've been in the NSA operations
rooms I've been on a u.s. spy plane over
the South China Sea
I see Americans in uniform and out out
of uniform fighting this battle every
day because they care about protecting
their country I care about the safety of
the country I've got three kids I want
them to live in a world as free as I was
able to to grow up in and travel the
world and you have two countries here
that are intent on changing the way the
world operates and if the country and if
our leaders don't fight back it's gonna
be a very different world all right Jim
judo you've written it was really good
you're very good oh my goodness you're a
great
no you're very good yeah really really
good thank you very much
you think you should send a couple
copies over to the White House okay I'll
rub them on yeah I think you should send
an autograph to the shadow war it's
available today wherever you'd like to
buy your books